>> IT'S THE CUOMO.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: YES, WELCOME BACK.
TWO BROTHERS WHO LEFT A TUSSLE.
ONE IS CHASING GIRLS, THE OTHER
ONE IS DOING CURLS.
ONE PRODUCT ON MY BROTHER IS
BUFF AND THE OTHER ONE SHOULD BE
IN CUFFS.
ONE IS IN CNN, THE OTHER SHOULD
BE IN THE STATE PEN.
WELCOME TO "IT'S THE CUOMO'S."
THERE LIKE CAIN AND ABEL, EXCEPT
ONE IS A PERV.
I DIDN'T HAVE ANY SUBTITLES.
GOVERNOR CUOMO HOLED UP IN HIS
MENTION FIGURING OUT HOW TO SAVE
HIS CAREER.
THAT IS ACCORDING TO
"THE NEW YORK POST" WHICH IS
OWNED BY A PARENT COMPANY,
PANDA EXPRESS.
THERE'S BEEN CALLS ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE FOR CUOMO TO RESIGN
FOLLOWING THE REPORT THAT CUOMO
SEXUALLY HIS OLD DOME I CARESSED
11 WOMEN.
MEANWHILE "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
SAY THAT THEY OFFERED HIM A
LEAVE OF ABSENCE IF HE WANTED TO
ADVISE HIS BROTHER ON HIS FEMALE
COLLEAGUES.
A LITTLE WORK OUT.
CHRIS NO, TELLING THE NETWORK
THAT'S CONVENIENT.
KRISTIN ADDRESSED THE REPORT
AFTER IT HAD ON TUESDAY, BUT HIS
POWELL DID FOLLOWING THE STORM
TOTALLY NORMAL HANDOFF.
>> OUR HEARTS AND THOUGHTS GO
OFF TO THE OFFICERS WHO TOOK
THEIR OWN LIVES.
I'M GOING TO MAKE MY WITNESS.
>> I LOVE YOU, BROTHER.
>> I LOVE YOU.
>> THIS IS DON LEMON TONIGHT.
THE CALLS ARE GETTING LOUDER AND
LOUDER.
THIS IS WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
TOP DEMOCRATS FROM NEW YORK TO
THE WHITE HOUSE CALLING ON
GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO TO RESIGN.
>> Greg: THAT IS AS AWKWARD --
THAT'S AS AWKWARD AS WATCHING A
MOVIE WITH YOUR PARENTS AND A
SCENE COMES ON.
GOD, I HATED OUR HOME MOVIES.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: JULIE, I HAVEN'T TALK
TO YOU ABOUT THIS.
WE DON'T TALK A LOT.
WE NEED TO TALK MORE.
>> CALL ME.
>> Greg: I WON'T.
DO YOU THINK ANDREW WILL STEP
DOWN?
I CALL HIM ANDREW, BUT HE IS THE
GOVERNOR.
>> NO, I DO NOT.
HE IS -- AS A FORMER NARCISSIST
COMPULSIVE LIAR, I HAVE
EXPERIENCE.
MAYBE HIGH SCHOOL COLLEGE COME A
LITTLE BIT OF ADULTHOOD, HE IS
TO LIE A LOT.
YOU KNOW, LIKE MINOR THINGS BUT
LIKE I GOT AN A CAR ACCIDENT
WHEN I WAS 16 AND I TOLD MY DAD
I GOT RUN OFF THE ROAD AND HIT A
TELEPHONE POLE, THE REAL STORY
WAS I SHOWING OFF INTO MY
FRIENDS AND I WHIPPED INTO A
DRIVEWAY AND RAN TO THE TREE IN
THE FRONT YARD.
HE WANTED TO SEE THE TREE OR THE
LIGHT POLE, AND I GOT SCREWED.
I SHOPLIFTED A COUPLE TIMES.
I WAS VERY YOUNG.
AND I GOT CAUGHT.
HOW DOES THIS END UP IN YOUR
BAG?
I DIDN'T PUT IT THERE SOMEBODY
ELSE MUST HAVE.
BUT THESE ARE THE KIND OF
COMPULSIVE LIES THAT DO NOT
SURPRISE ME.
SO WHEN YOU COME FORWARD AND YOU
SAY, YOU KNOW, DENY, DENY, DENY.
LIKE WHEN I CHEWED UP MY
BOYFRIEND WHEN I WAS 17 YEARS
OLD.
THAT IS WHAT YOU GET FOR
EAVESDROPPING, SHAME ON YOU.
SO SHAME ON YOU, BECAUSE I KNOW,
I SPEAK FROM EXPERIENCE.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY HE'S GOING TO
DRIVE US THROUGH THE MUD.
>> Greg: HE DID THAT.
WHAT YOU ARE DESCRIBING SHOULD
BE CALLED A CUOMO WHICH IS WHEN
THEY CATCH YOU IN A LIE, YOU
TURN IT BACK ON THEM.
>> ALWAYS!
>> Greg: I'M TELLING YOU, I
WAS A PRO.
I MEAN, MUCH, MUCH LONG AGO.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, KAT.
IF HE DOESN'T STEP DOWN, WHAT
DOES THAT DO TO THIS ME TOO
MOVEMENT?
>> I THINK IT'S HORRIBLE,
BECAUSE THE ME TOO MOVEMENT --
THIS IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
WHAT WE ARE SUPPOSED TO FIGHT
AGAINST.
A GUY IN A POWERFUL POSITION
ABUSING HIS POWER TO ABUSE
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE POWER.
AND THERE'S THIS INVESTIGATION
WITH 11 VICTIMS CORROBORATED --
THAT HE DID THIS.
SO IF HE FACES NO CONSEQUENCES,
THAT IS GOING TO BE REALLY BAD
FOR ANY WOMAN WHO IS EVER IN A
SITUATION NOW OR IN THE FUTURE.
BECAUSE IF THAT'S NOT ENOUGH,
THEN WHAT WOULD EVER BE ENOUGH?
THERE ARE ASPECTS OF THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT -- THAT STUFF.
BUT THIS IS WHAT IT WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE ABOUT AND WHY IT IS
IMPORTANT.
SO I CERTAINLY -- SHE'S GOT TO
GO.
THERE ARE SEVEN INVESTIGATIONS
INTO HIM AT THIS POINT.
JUST GO!
>> Greg: BUCK, HOW DOES HE
GOVERN?
AND I'M TALKING ABOUT CHRIS
CUOMO.
>> CHRIS CUOMO?
PRO-CUOMO AS WE CALL HIM.
>> Greg: HOW DO YOU CONTINUE
DOING YOUR JOB WHEN YOU CAN'T
EVEN COVER THE NEWS?
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT --
OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN TALK ABOUT THE
RETIREMENT HOMES ARE THE NURSING
HOMES.
>> THIS GUY IS UTTERLY
SHAMELESS.
HE THINKS THAT HE IS THE
GOVERNOR.
THERE'S NO 11 ALSO COULD HAVE
THE JOB.
HE'S NOT GOING TO STEP DOWN,
HE'S GONNA FORCE THEM TO TRY TO
PULL IN THROUGH THE IMPEACHMENT
PROCESS WHICH WILL TAKE 60-90
DAYS.
BY THAT POINT, WE WILL BE DEEPER
INTO COVID, MAYBE WE'LL HAVE THE
VACCINE PASSPORTS AND THE REST
OF IT.
HE HAD A SMOOCH MONTAGE VIDEO AS
PART OF HIS DEFENSE.
I KISSED LADIES ON THE FACE, ON
THE HAD COME ON THE FOOT COME ON
THE SHOULDER, THE WHOLE THING.
AND WE'RE SITTING THERE SAYING,
WELL, THERE YOU GO.
HE'S JUST LIKE EVERYBODY GETS A
SMOOCH.
PLUS BIDEN'S NEXT LADIES HAD,
LET'S REMEMBER.
SO HIS OPEN PEOPLE WON'T PAY
ATTENTION.
>> Greg: THIS IS WHY BRING UP
CHRIS CUOMO A LOT.
WHO COMES UP WITH MONTAGES?
PEOPLE IN TV.
THE MONTAGE IS BORN FROM PEOPLE
LIKE US, PRODUCERS WHO SAY HEY,
WE NEED TO SHOW HOW STUPID THIS
PERSON IS PAIRED LET'S SHOW A
MONTAGE.
HIS BROTHER -- HIS BROTHER HAD
TO DO IT.
>> HIS BROTHER WHO WAS HELPING
HIM, BY THE WAY.
I MEAN, THIS IS PART OF THE
GAME, RIGHT?
YOU HAVE TO PAY THESE PEOPLE TO
BE YOUR CONSULTANTS, BECAUSE
THEN THEY ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
AT THE FOREFRONT OF THE
WEAPONIZATION OF ME TOO MOVEMENT
AGAINST CERTAIN PEOPLE,
REPUBLICANS BEAR THEY WAYS WANT
TO USE IT WHEN THEY WANT TO USE
IT.
AS FOR THE MOVEMENT OVERALL, IF
YOU PAY OFF THE RIGHT PEOPLE NOW
YOU WILL GET THE EXPERTISE OF
THE TIME'S UP FOLKS.
BEING CONSULTED ON WHETHER OR
NOT THIS WILL HELP CUOMO AVOID
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT, BUT THE
TIMES UP PEOPLE ARE SUPPOSED TO
TELL US WHO SHOULD GET IN
TROUBLE FOR ME TO.
>> THEY ALL WORK AMONGST EACH
OTHER.
>> Greg: AND THEY WORK FOR
DEMOCRATS BEAR THEY DON'T WORK
FOR REPUBLICANS.
>> TO ME, THIS ALL GOES BACK TO
THE 1996, 1997, MONICA LEWINSKY.
WHEN FEMINIST GROUPS DECIDED TO
SIDE WITH BILL CLINTON OVER
MONICA LEWINSKY PRITT AND THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE NEVER LEARNED
THEIR LESSON AND THEY CONTINUE
TO PAY THE PRICE OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
THIS IS NOT LIKE ANDREW CUOMO
WHO WAS ON THE ZOOM AND
ACCIDENTALLY FORGOT THE CAMERA
WAS ON OR WHAT EVER HAPPENED.
ONE OF THE THINGS WAS HE CHANGED
THE RULES SO THAT THE ONE GAL
WHO WORKED ON THE STATE
TROOPERS -- HE HAD HIS EYE ON.
SO THAT SHE COULD ACTUALLY COME
TO WORK FOR HIM.
AND THEN HE STARTED TO HARASS
HER AND EVERYBODY AROUND
ANDREW CUOMO KNEW IT.
SO CHRIS CUOMO DOESN'T HAVE TO
SAY ANYTHING ABOUT IT, IT'S
SUPER CONVENIENT.
>> Greg: CNN SAID A LOT OF
WEIRD ISSU